however not everyone watching thank you
so much for featuring my ideas my
thoughts I've been following you for a
long long time so I'm really excited to
see this come together a weed is the
intention that you don't want and the
problem is sometimes you've let it grow
so much the weed looks like the plant
you can take a fish out of water and
give it a beautiful mansion and a
Bentley and all the money in the world
but it would die and that's what we are
like our environment I realized that if
you really want to be good at something
you have to invest in it with all your
life you have to become addicted and
absorb to improvement and growth need
motivation watch a top tenant believe
nation what's up at seven my one word is
believe and I believe in you I believe
you have an amazing gift inside you that
I want to see exploded onto the world so
let's get your motivation to attend and
get you believing in you grab a snack
and chew on today's lessons from a man
who went from being bullied as a child
for being overweight and nerdy to
traveling and living as a monk in India
and across Europe and being one of the
most viewed people on the internet he's
Jay Shetty and here's my take on his top
ten rules of success the joy
alright let's kick things off with rule
number one be exposed to new experiences
at 18 I was really fortunate when I met
a monk
and this monk was invited to speak and I
kind of just went because one of my
friends forced me to at that time I was
listening to CEOs and entrepreneurs and
business people and marketers who who I
thought that's what I was aspiring to be
like and then I hear this monk and he
captivated me like no one had ever
captivated me before it was like staring
at the most beautiful woman on the
planet you know I was completely fixated
on him and his message see we live in
echo chambers we're just surrounded by
the same thinking how often do you bump
into a monk you know it just doesn't
happen you don't have no one has a
dinner party and goes oh yeah written by
the monk you know from a town like the
local monk like no one ever does that
and so you meet people who are just like
us most of the time and we talked about
this in business bulletin if you want to
be a billionaire spend time with
billionaires if you want to be a
millionaire spent on millionaires if you
want to be a tech startup spend time
with you know that's that's the common
rhetoric that we hear all the time but
what if you want to find purpose and
master the mind there's no one better
than a monk who's mastered the mind so
for me the first step is just opening
yourself up to new experiences and new
role models because most of us can't see
ourselves in people so then we try and
fit ourselves into the boxes that we do
see and and I mean there's this
beautiful quote that I've been saying it
everywhere and I wish I wrote it but I
didn't so it's by a philosopher and
writer named Cooley and he said that
today I'm not what I think I am I'm not
what you think I am I am what I think
you think I am I understand that blow
your mind for me it's so powerful I'm
not what I think I am I'm not what you
think I am I am what I think you think I
am so we live in this perception of a
perception of ourselves
hence my identity is made by what my
parents think I should be my identity is
made up by what my college or university
thinks
should achieve while you're living in
that bubble and that echo chamber
getting to what you really want to do is
impossible because maybe that just
doesn't fit and I think so many people
feel that way today but they don't fit
into the current education system they
don't fit with the three or four or five
careers that you're taught exist so that
process of self excavation and
actualization first requires being
exposed you can't be what you can't see
if I never saw a monk I would never have
wanted to be a monk if I never meet a
billionaire I wouldn't want to be one
because I wouldn't know what that feels
like I don't know what it looks like I
don't know what it takes and and I think
that's the biggest challenge of our
society that we're not exposed so that's
the first step being exposed to unique
experiences and role models second step
is finding that experience of role model
that you're passionate about and exactly
like you said taking it seriously shadow
the network with them spend time with
them observe them even from afar it
takes that observation being addicted to
observing that person's lifestyle and
then the third step is growing yes or no
does that work for me not everyone who's
gonna go off from the camera monkeys
gonna feel like the way I did and that's
cool but not everyone is gonna go and
follow and shadow a billion anger that's
exactly the lifestyle I want they may
want the result but do they want the
hard work that goes with it and so for
me that's the third step its observing
focusing shadowing getting as close to
the process of that individual and then
going yes or no do I want that process
not do I want the result everyone wants
to be that monk who's fully enlightened
you know can walk through as an
incredible or that people just gravitate
towards but when you realize he has to
wake up at 2:00 a.m. every day and
stitch about four to six hours you're
like ah you know I don't want to like me
rule number two my personal favorite
believe the second thing we usually get
wrong is that we don't believe in what
we're sharing I've realized that I've
grown much more confident about speaking
in front of people and even in front of
you right now on video because I talk
but stuff that's really meaningful to me
that's really purposeful to me I only
choose to share messages that truly
resonate with my heart and my head and
my intelligence and things that I've
immersed myself in for a number of years
everything I'm sharing these stories
these ideas they aren't just made up to
sound good these are things that I
really truly try and live and practice
and embody in my own day-to-day life and
therefore if you don't really believe in
what you're speaking about if you don't
really understand it if you haven't
tried to live it then you're always
going to struggle trying to articulate
it and even if you get away with
articulating something perfectly that
you don't believe in you'll feel empty
inside and that's why sales rolls
usually end up making people feel quite
empty because they're selling stuff and
products that they don't think will
change your life make sure if you're
trying to communicate a message for your
brand if you're trying to sell a product
if you're sharing insights and ideas
they have to be things that genuinely
connect with you internally this feels
weird for you are you sure this is legal
rule number three refine your intention
my daily practice is to refine my
intention that the biggest weeds that we
all get is an i intention so when I say
intention I mean my current intention is
to use everything I've been given
everything that I have in the service of
others so I want to use the following
that I have to help people I want to use
the money that I have to help people I
want to use the network that I have to
help people but every day that intention
which is a beautiful little plant that's
growing gets weeds around it no do it
for the money right - for the face just
do it for the fame do it for the
followers do it for this all these weeds
are like going around my real intention
every day every day that's a weed a weed
is the intention that you don't want and
the problem is sometimes you've let it
grow so much the weed looks like the
plant right weed looks like your
intention and you start believing it's
the same thing so for me my daily
practice is going back in reflecting on
what is my voice right now in my head
what am I saying to myself and I'm
hearing make that deal
a lot of money do this do that do this
more followers Fame all that stuff and
I'm cutting it down I'm cutting that
weed every day and you've got to do it
every day because the more you're
surrounded by that energy right the more
it's gonna keep creeping in like a
creeper weed rule number four know your
element environment and energy so for me
my three e's are element environment and
energy every one has an element that
they thrive in if you take someone out
of it their element they won't be the
same modern-day example would be Michael
Jordan he was incredible at basketball
he took him at a basketball put him in a
baseball no one remembers his career we
talk about one the best athletes of all
time your environment is the environment
around you you can take a fish out of
water and give it a beautiful mansion
and a Bentley and all the money in the
world but it would die and that's what
we are like our environment everyone is
an environment which they thrive which
we have to craft your boss if you're at
work is never gonna ask you what
environment you succeed in right like
that never happens so we have to create
an environment where we thrive and then
finally it's energy we some of us love
high energy environments high pressure
some of us succeed in lower energy
environments and low pressure figuring
out your energy and the frequency on
which you operate best will help you
thrive as well so for me those are the
three e's to really create a thriving
environment know your element know your
environment and know your energy and so
on all times if I see anything going
wrong I'm going is my element out of
alignment is my environment out of
alignment or is my energy out of
alignment that's a great three question
test you can do to yourself when you
don't think things are going right and
all you have to do is bring that back
into alignment rule number five practice
you usually don't practice enough I
realized that if you really want to be
good at something you have to invest in
it with all your life you have to become
addicted and absorb to improvement and
growth that means being open to feedback
that means being open to what the
experts have to say about you
not being attached to your ego and how
you feel about yourself but opening up
yourself to an expert group of people to
give you insights on how you can grow
evolve and perform at a higher rate and
linked to that is practice practice
practice it's literally impossible to do
something perfectly the first time you
do it the more you do it the better you
get and we think practice is a cliche
that we hear all the time but actually
it's that truth it's so simple you might
miss it did I miss something here rule
number six make it happen right now I'd
like you to fast forward to seventy
eighty ninety years old right fast
forward in your mind to that age 70 80
90 100 110 if you're really optimistic
whichever one it is and I'd like you to
write down what will be the things that
you'll regret that you didn't do
imagine you're that age ask yourself the
question what would I regret that I
didn't do know what you did do about
what you didn't do
write it down make a long list right now
get a pen and paper out and write it
down don't do on your phone don't do on
your laptop actually get a pen and paper
and write down your answers and what
will be the things that you regret that
you didn't do right really think about
it would it be you know learning a new
language will it be moving home will it
be telling someone you love them what
will it be what would have been write it
down right now now the incredible thing
about this question is that you're using
the future to empower the past whatever
answer you have in that question
whatever your answer is you can do it
right now today starting today because
you're not that age and if you're even
if you're 64 and you're tuning in 70 80
90 you're still there right it's still
possible you can start doing that right
now it's empowering the present with the
future there is nothing stopping you
from making it happen right now you
don't have to feel that way when you're
70 you don't have to feel that way when
you're 80 you never ever have to feel
that way if you start doing it right now
and you can do it right now even if it
feels impossible you can stop working on
it right now you can start trying right
now you can start making plans right now
because you're not there yet and this is
where you
this is where you start making it happen
it's all in the now rule number seven
find your passion so how do I find my
passion my simple model which is the
Dharma model it also dharma means
eternal duty in the Vedic tradition it's
very similar to what a key guy is being
spoken about today which is a Japanese
version of reason for being why do we
live where is meaning coming from and it
talks about an intersect of four areas
what am I good at what do I love what is
the world need and how do I get paid for
it to me those four help you unlock your
passion when you find the intersect
across all of those four you're making
your passion your purpose you'll unlock
your passion you'll find your purpose
this is path one there's two paths path
one I find my skill set and I engage it
to help other people and become better
at it so I'm becoming better at what I'm
good at and I'm using it to help other
people because I'm aware of what I'm
quite good at and I know what more
knowledge I have what skills I have I
have some self-awareness the other path
that people often miss is actually I
just start serving people I just start
helping people and I start to notice
what I enjoy about that and what I'm
good at helping people with so that's
Gandhi's path Gandhi said that you find
yourself when you lose yourself in the
service of others so for me those are
the two paths of how do I find my
passion and finding the intersect
between those four areas rule number
eight overcome challenges you have to
remind yourself that it's okay to feel
the way you feel when you're going for a
difficult time it's okay to feel weak
it's okay to want to cry it's okay to
feel overwhelmed just reminding yourself
that it's okay this is my number one way
of how to find strength in difficult
times is reminding yourself that the way
you feel is okay to honor that feeling
to accept that feeling to actually be
okay with that what we see or what we
perceive to be a weakness what we
perceive to let us down or what we
perceive is a sign of you know
instability or insecurity we've got to
remind ourselves that when things are
tough it's okay to feel that way there's
nothing wrong with that any difficulty I
go to I look to mom
in history where people have enjoyed the
same pain if not more extreme and
analyzed absorb and connect with how
they got through it I like to see what
they were thinking I like to see what
they did I like to see how they
structured themselves I like to look at
how they organized I looked like to look
at who they were speaking to I like to
look at what was going through their
mind at that time because you've got to
remember that any challenge we're facing
today we've faced it before as a as
humanity right beyond ethnicities beyond
color race creed beyond backgrounds
beyond all walks of life as human beings
we've been through challenges before and
we've got through them and therefore
reconnecting with how that's been done
before is a beautiful way of learning
how to overcome current challenges so
you can either look at your past but
real wisdom lies in looking at the past
the people who made a difference you
look at people like Martin Luther King
you look at people like Gandhi you look
at people who made world-changing
differences not single-handedly but
influenced from a single perspective
from a single point of view and really
connecting with the powerful moments in
history I've said this quote many times
I've read it many times and this quote
actually is is unbelievable and the
quote says that they fought they buried
us they didn't know we were seeds right
it's a Mexican proverb they thought they
borrowed us they didn't know we were
seeds and I was thinking these when you
tell yourself that story
you start thinking much more differently
right a seed is buried - it's incredible
that the seed goes through the same
process as anything else it's put deep
underground right all of this mud is put
on top of it it gets rained on it gets
snowed on all these kind of things but
it knows that it's a seed so it knows
that it can grow so there anything's
possible and it grows through and you
see even plants growing through concrete
sometimes right it's unbelievable how
much power a seed has so changing the
stories we tell ourselves we can either
look at challenging situations as
opportunities for growth as an
opportunity to learn as
opportunity to change be the change we
can look at them and and really fool
down now that that second part is okay
we can even feel like that right but we
have to recognize it's not permanent
we've gotta accept that none of our
feelings are permanent they don't need
to be permanent it's a choice so if you
need to vent vent I was saying to
someone yesterday if you need a vent
vent if you need to run run if you need
to complain complain if you need to
share how you feel do that but recognize
that those feelings are not permanent
and it'll be amazing when we've realized
we are seeds right that is the most
powerful way of finding strength rule
number nine redefine failure in the
middle of 2009 he was the software
engineer that no one wanted to hire he
had 12 years of experience at Yahoo but
he was rejected by Facebook and then
rejected by Twitter
he'd been to a great university he had a
great CV but he decided to team up with
one of his alumni members at Yahoo and
started to create an app and focus on
the startup space in five years time he
sold that out for 19 billion dollars to
Facebook believe it or not that was
Brian Acton the co-founder of whatsapp
when he was rejected from Facebook he
said it was a great opportunity to
connect with some fantastic people I
look forward to life's next adventure
when he was rejected by Twitter he
responded by saying worked-out ills by a
long commute it's so interesting to see
that someone rejected from two of the
top internet companies actually
responded with humor and actually
responded with positivity this lady was
diagnosed with clinical depression her
marriage had failed and she was jobless
with a dependent child she was on a
four-hour delayed train journey from
Manchester to London when she came up
with this idea and she started to write
this book about this wizard and as she
started writing she then finished her
manuscript to get the 12 publishers and
was rejected by all 12 believe it or not
that's JK Rowling this man watched his
first company crumble he was a Harvard
University dropout and his first
company's demo didn't even work he went
on to build Microsoft his name's bill
therefore failure is just a sign that we
need to widen our scope we need to be
ready and build ourselves up for the
next level actually what we end up
achieving is far greater than what we'd
envisioned for ourselves and this divine
plan this orchestration can't be
happening without this intervention that
occurs because if we had it our way we
just settle we just accept what we
thought was our goal what we thought we
were chasing but actually I've noticed
that when you don't get that later down
the line you look back and you reflect
and realize that what you've gained is
so much greater failures are only
failures when we don't learn from them
because when we learn from them they
become lessons and we actually extract a
lay all of these teachings and actually
get more insight into how we can improve
the way we work and how we can actually
drive with a different energy the
challenge we have is that we only talk
about people's failures when they
succeed and that's why they become this
taboo or we feel like their failures
never happened we need to share these
stories earlier we need to bring out
these stories and experiences on the
journey so that people who are on the
journey can actually follow in those
footsteps
and that's why Steve Jobs said you can't
connect the dots moving forward
you only can when you're looking
backwards and rule number 10 the last
one before the bonus Clips is decide to
be a pilot in life you're either a
passenger or a pilot you've got that
choice this is one of the biggest
choices you'll ever make are you
defining what direction you're moving in
or
you letting other people make the
biggest decisions of where you're going
see it first is more comfortable being
the passenger you sit back relax have
people serve you it feels easier it
feels more natural but then as time goes
by you look outside the window and you
realize you've ended up somewhere that
you didn't want to be then you start
blaming people around you blaming people
who made those decisions for you blaming
people who should take responsibility
for what you've ended up sometimes you
feel lost confused and wonder how you
ever got there and in that moment at
that time you've got this important
choice to make you can either switch
seats grab hold of the steering wheel
and start guiding your life or remain a
passenger you can't be both which one
are you
heaven and everyone watching thank you
so much for featuring my ideas and my
thoughts I've been following you for a
long long time so I'm really excited to
see this come together and for every one
of you watching he's picked some
incredible clips and I'm really grateful
for that and I hope that these bytes of
wisdom these insights truly transform
and touch your lives I come I feel to
see them thank you so much see you soon
now I've got three very special jay
Shetty bonus clips on how to use your
head and your heart how to use regret to
fuel you and how to find happiness but
before that I want to get to the
commitment of the day you watch this
video I don't want you to just watch it
on the video and not take action after
watching all of these clips what
commitment are you making to improve in
your business or your life leave it down
the comments below I'm excited to see
your commitment thank you guys so much
for watching I believe in you I hope you
continue to believe in yourself and
whatever your one where it is much love
I'll see you soon and enjoy the bonus
clips
so in an ideal life for me is a life and
this applies to a company and
organization and institution for me is
an ideal life is when we all have a head
a heart and a hand all three elements
together working in alignment without
one or the other we start to lose
something if you only are the head in a
heart you find that life is stable and
defined yes yeah sure sure sure sure so
ahead is the clarity of vision what you
want what you want knowing what you want
the way you picture life and being able
to navigate make the decisions to get
that that's a good head a good heart is
being able to understand what your
intuition and heart ones being able to
connect and tap into that understanding
deeper and beyond the vision you may
have painted for yourself so I often say
to people that you get to where you want
in life just not in the way you imagined
and that's because the path that's paved
up and down is far different to the path
we pave so you can have a great head and
a great vision and a great mission and
know where you want to go but if your
heart's not able to have that resilience
and be able to adapt and and have
compassion and care and all of that then
then you're not going to be able to make
the toughest decisions without your
heart but to be able to realize that we
need to care and be sustainable and
long-lasting requires a heart and a hand
is that service wanting to pass that on
that which you have wanting to give it
forward pay it forward the idea of
serving with what you have I often say
to people your passion is for you your
purpose is for others your passion makes
you happy but when you use your passion
to make a difference in someone else's
life that's a service that's a purpose
and that's the hand so those are my
three elements of an ideal life one of
the things that when things don't work
out one of the things I've been telling
myself and also thinking about a lot is
apart from the fact of learning which
we'll go into is just that space I'm
actually understanding that there may be
a different route see we get so attached
to having one
one method one way of working we believe
that there's only one pathway to where
we want to be there's this conveyor belt
of things we have to do whether it's you
know get a degree find a partner buy a
house you know play golf whatever it is
like this conveyor belt of efficiency
and productivity that we hear that
becomes a part of our natural
progression and when that breaks apart
that's when we start to worry that's
when we start to think but notice that
then actually it's a lot better when
that happens earlier in life see regret
has some really important roles the
first one is that it helps us make sense
of the world from our perspective for
one of the first time see most of us
have spent our lives learning what's
important to us based on maybe what
families or what communities - what
parents do what education - whatever it
is when you star ragrange something a
new thing you did something wrong when
you start thinking that I could have
done something differently you're making
sense of the world from your perspective
it's crazy how powerful this is right
you're starting to make sense of the
world from your perspective the second
thing is it allows you to avoid future
negative behavior if you know you
regretted something why don't you write
it down right now
right if you regret something write it
down right now because it will teach you
so much in the future and you've got to
write down the lesson you learn now
otherwise next time when you think
you're making another tough decision
you're gonna say to yourself oh what did
I do last time how did I not make myself
regret that and then you're gonna be
upset you're gonna regret that you
didn't write it down
so write it down right now we need to
define what success means for us we need
to redefine what success means let's not
make happiness and success about the
size of our homes but about the size of
our heart let's not make it about
gratification but gratitude we speak
about being healthy and our well being
but we act more like human doings than
we do like human beings and therefore
instead of to-do list
need to be lists instead of continue
about what you want to do think about
who you want to be if you want to be
more self-aware deem to be more
conscious even to be a better person you
want to be a difference in the world we
need to move away from what we want to
do in situations to really want to be in
situations the three most common things
that we forget when we're rushing out of
our homes is our keys our wallet or our
mobile phone and it's absolutely
hilarious how you run back inside you'll
open all your drawers we look in your
desk you make a mess sometimes and then
how many times have you had it that you
realize it was actually in your back
pocket sometimes even in your hand and
it's funny that our experience of
happiness is so similar to this we run
around trying to find it in absolutely
every place but actually when we come
back
find out that it's within what would see
was wolves volume yeah the most
important work ever if you had to think
of one word that's most important to you
or that sums you Apple that would be
collect a little beacon pay believe
nation if you want to know what the most
important one word is for Tony Robbins
Gary Vaynerchuk Oprah Winfrey will.i.am
and Howard Schultz I have a very special
secret video for you check the
description for details
[Music]